der andere ort wo menschen erleiden ist
mario kohle und dort hat unser reporter
philipp potthoff ja einen ganz
besonderen kontakt hinbekommen und zwar
über wesloer ihr mann ist dort in
mariupol in diesem stahlwerk und das
einzige mittel mit dem sie kontakt
halten kann mit ihrem mann ist whatsapp
philippiak oft hat sie besucht die
hafenstadt mario pohl sie ist
vergangenheit nach zwei monaten nichts
übrig und doch mittendrin menschen
tausende menschen hier im stahlwerk as
of style mario pohl auf diesem
unwirklichen gelände hier sind sie die
letzten menschen von morgen wohl frauen
und noch immer kinder und die letzten
kämpfer ausgehungert in den katakomben
des stahlwerks sie haben nur ein ziel
irgendwie überleben irgendwie sie sind
eingekesselt durch die russischen
truppen seit wochen abgeschnitten von
der welt fast denn bild trifft wetzlarer
aus mario pohl eine junge mutter mit
ihren drei kleinen kindern ihr mann war
ihm sitzt im stahlwerk fest
[Musik]
in aadorf stahl sind mehr als 2000
menschen in einem bunker aus drei ebenen
auf jeder ebene sind sehr viele menschen
die
militärs sind getrennt von den frauen
und den kindern es gibt sogar säuglinge
es sind sehr viele verletzte zivile und
soldaten die stimmung ist kämpferisch
aber die vorräte gehen zu ende deswegen
warten sie auf unterstützung sie müssen
dort herausgeholt werden sie brauchen
hilfe
entweder
diplomatisch oder mit dem militär aber
sie müssen irgendwie dort herausgeholt
werden
während draußen der frühling kommt und
die kinder auf dem trampolin spielen und
die gedanken immer bei papa warten der
sie an sein leben klammert im stahlwerk
von mario pohl
eine winzige hoffnung dieses handy wann
kommt die nächste nachricht von ihm gibt
es doch noch hoffnung wird er irgendwann
sagen können ich bin da raus raus aus
der hölle
[Musik]
wenn ich frage ob sie noch nahrung und
wasser haben schweigt er nur er will
mich nicht beunruhigen
sie sind sehr kämpferisch eingestellt
aber alle vorräte gehen zu ende deswegen
warten sie auf hilfe sie wollen raus
geholt werden egal wie ob durch
verhandlungen oder militärisch
wir sagen denen dass wir alles tun
werden um sie aus dem bunker rauszuholen
dass sie die hoffnung und den glauben
nicht verlieren sollen dass sie weiter
glauben sollen dass sie auf jeden fall
gerettet werden
wir hoffen auf die unterstützung der
ganzen welt dass der frieden wieder
kommt dass uns geholfen wird
wir wünschen uns
so schnell wie möglich frieden wo er
sein und ruhr
die zwölfjährige war da sehnt sich für
ihre beiden kleinen brüder danach ihren
vater endlich wieder in die arme
schließen zu können bis dahin bleibt
auch ihr nur der kontakt über das handy
sie hat ihm geschrieben dass ihr papa
ein held ist dass er nicht traurig sein
soll dass sie glaubt dass er zurückkommt
und bei uns sein wird
[Musik]